it roams the night bellowing
blood-curdling screams in search of dead
and dying prey and when it tears into
flesh it's with some of the most bone
crushing jaws on earth this fiendish
fighter may look cute but its name says
it all the Tasmanian devil
Tasmanian Devils as their name suggests
can only be found in one place
Tasmania this Australian Islands forests
and dense foliage allow a resting devil
to lay low by day but by night the same
landscape becomes a shrieking stalking
ground Tasmanian Devils are the
Kangaroos crankiest cousin like most
marsupials they start as tiny specks in
their mother's pouch they don't get as
big as their fleet-footed relatives Tazi
Devils only reach two feet and weigh
just under 30 pounds but what they lack
in size they make up for in strength
Devils huge heads hold powerful crushing
jaws and their bite is even worse than
their ear splitting bark the Tasmanian
Devil has the strongest bite force of
any living mammal on earth capable of
ripping through flesh and bone
the devil's bite force comes from a
powerful upper-body design the Taz ease
massive head is disproportionately
larger than the rest of its torso and
supports an unusually prominent and
powerful mouth to date Taz's have killed
no humans but inadvertent encounters
with devils kenan in bloodshed one of
the only ways to observe them is in
protected animal parks it takes
determination
something had mammal keeper Tim Faulkner
of the Australian Reptile Park knows
firsthand his routine devil check up
quickly turns into a howling scuffle
anyone who studies Tazz ease up close
risks painful run-ins with muscular jaws
that work like a snapping sling so
you'll see that they've got a very large
lumpy jawbone and most of that is muscle
it comes right up over the top of their
forward and attaches at the back of the
ears and at the bottom of the years and
allows the pressure of the jaws to close
[Music]